[Music]
this is your Tech news briefing for
Tuesday November 8th I'm Zoe Thomas for
The Wall Street Journal since taking
over Twitter Elon Musk has reiterated
his idea that the platform should be a
global Town Square to share ideas but
what ideas get shared or promoted could
be a problem not just for advertisers on
Twitter but for musk's other businesses
Tesla for example relies heavily on
China a place where speech is often
tightly restricted and where the
government often tries to control the
narrative about it outside its borders
as well so how could musk's new
ownership of Twitter affect his EV
company and its ties to Beijing
joining us to discuss that is Stephen
Wilmot you're a editor for the Wall
Street journals heard on the street
column hi Stephen thanks for joining us
hi there
so Twitter is officially blocked in
China but it is used by some companies
and individuals who can find some
workarounds can you lay out what
beijing's view of Twitter is and how
much it cares about what is said about
it well they take a dubious view to
Twitter just like they do to other US
tech platforms who are mostly banned in
China and obviously the whole idea of
being able to express your opinions very
openly is a bit inimicable to beijing's
authoritarian Tendencies and I would say
the other way in which they have a
relationship with Twitter as it were is
that they've been accused of producing
content to influence U.S elections and
so forth so okay so let's talk about
some of the broader connections between
musk and China and one of the big ones
being Tesla can you talk about how much
Tesla needs China
is really important to Tesla it's hard
to overstate how important it is even in
the context of the Auto industry work
China is the largest market and it's
been the largest profit pool for a long
time and Tesla makes about a quarter of
its revenues in China but that's in a
way not the main source of dependency
the main source of dependencies in
production so it's Shanghai factories by
far its biggest production base and it's
also its hub for Global exports Tesla is
trying to diversify away from its
Reliance on China a bit by building up
production in Germany and More in Texas
at this point about 40 of its production
capacities in China how difficult is it
to diversify away from China I mean you
mentioned it's working on factories in
Germany and Texas but is that a quick
process is that one that's really going
to separate it a lot from Beijing no
it's going to take time and one of the
other facets is it's not just production
like final assembly of cars but it's
also the whole supply chain and in
common with the rest of the EV industry
and this isn't a Tesla specific thing
but the whole EV industry has a huge
dependence on China because of the
battery supply chain because of China's
industrial policy and its subsidies for
EVS and this is the problem here that
you know much of Elon musk's wealth is
tied up in this company over which China
has a lot of Leverage and I guess then
the question is what does that leverage
mean for Tesla if
something happens on Twitter that
Beijing disapproves of are they going to
hold that against Tesla in some way I
mean that's a really interesting
question
a whole battery supply chain kind of
being tied up with China so other
electric vehicle makers and also you
know companies like apple making their
iPhones there how have they negotiated
dealing with Beijing and making sure the
Chinese government stays happy while
also being global companies because I
guess it's worth wondering how that
worked for companies that aren't social
media companies that aren't dealing with
content moderation
sure I mean most companies just try and
keep very quiet politically apple is
obviously another us company that's very
dependent on China because of its Supply
chains and Tim Cook the CEO of Apple
tends not to make big political
statements tries to satisfy all sides
it's the same with the established car
industry VW BMW they have a big
dependence on China if they ever make
any kind of political statement it tends
to be very generic like they support
global trade something like that and
Elon Musk tends to do things differently
for better or worse and you know he's
used political statements to really
ingratiate himself with the regime in
Beijing most recently over Taiwan so
we've talked about Taiwan finding some
accommodation with Beijing anyway
Beijing loved it Taiwan less so and he's
actually done the same with Putin in
Russia last month but Russia's a less
important market so he has this
interesting record of ingratiating
himself somehow with these authoritarian
regimes that might also like build a
luxury cars whilst also playing the kind
of White Knight for free speech in the
US and although he's managed to kind of
walk that line successfully so far it
gets a lot harder with this Twitter
purchase because suddenly all of these
the global elements like the
misinformation campaigns that might be
run by Russia or China or Iran on
Twitter they suddenly become his problem
has he said anything about how he might
deal with things like that particularly
say misinformation campaigns I'm not
aware that he said anything I mean at
the moment he's obviously made clear
that he's
going to leave content moderation the
way it is and he's desperately trying to
keep the status quo for now and I think
this is mainly for the benefit of
advertisers at this point rather than
because relations with foreign regimes
have become a flash point the risk
really is I think to Tesla's
Chinese operations I mean the Chinese
regime has a history of discouraging
consumers from purchasing consumer
products when there are geopolitical
tensions it's happened with certain
Japanese companies it's happened with
certain South Korean companies at
certain points so Tesla is particularly
it was always perhaps a risk from rising
geopolitical tensions but it seems like
it's much more at risk now
does it seem like the U.S or other
Western countries might also put
pressure on Twitter or on Tesla given
the relationship that it has with China
absolutely obviously the scrutiny of
social media has only grown in Western
regimes so it certainly doesn't feel
like it will be easy for musk to dial
back any of the
content restrictions in a way that would
you know make it easy I suppose for
pro-chinese voices to be heard or
anything like that he's stuck between
this U.S Paradigm of free speech and the
reality that his Global car
manufacturing Empire relies on an
authoritarian regime in a very large
part and he's trying to juggle so many
balls that you wonder when One's Gonna
drop I guess we'll just have to watch
and see that's Stephen Wilmot Europe
editor for the Wall Street journals
heard on the street column thank you so
much for joining us thanks very much for
having me on the show
and that's it for today's Tech news
briefing if you want more Tech stories
check out our website
wsj.com I'm Zoe Thomas for The Wall
Street Journal
thanks for listening
[Music]